throughout this week we've been talking
qualitatively about the feeling that joe
biden's presidency has turned around
we've listed the different
accomplishments over the last two three
months and particularly over the last
three to four weeks but we didn't yet
have anything quantitative to answer the
question is there really a turnaround
happening is joe biden's approval
actually increasing and the reason we
care about that is not so much as a
curiosity although it's interesting to
see a president have such a low approval
rating for a while and then see it
recover because 10 what tends to happen
during presidencies is there's an
erosion of approval over time
um
what is interesting about it is its
impact on the november midterms which
are now just roughly uh
nine weeks or so away by very very very
rough estimate looking at the calendar
if indeed joe biden's approval rating
continues to increase at the rate at
which it has over the last 10 days
it is all of a sudden looking very bad
for republicans in november so the first
question is what are the numbers well
joe biden's approval rating has spiked
11
in a very short period of time now for
those who
may or may not understand the precision
with which i am speaking
11
increase is not an 11 point increase
the approval rating of joe biden
bottomed out at 37 and a half
right on july 21st and it has now gone
up to 41.6
that is of course not an increase of 11
percentage points but it is an 11
increase in one month that is
significant and if you see even
half or two thirds of that increase
continue until november you're going to
have a quite popular joe biden
on the day of the midterm elections
because these midterms are in a sense
referenda
on those in power which in this case
includes a democrat in the white house
democrats controlling the senate
although barely and democrats
controlling the house the conventional
wisdom would be that would be very good
for democrats and you can tell that
biden is sort of reinvigorated in a
sense he is back on the campaign trail
and starting to
be visibly campaigning for democrats
running in november yesterday at a rally
against a trump allied
republican in maryland
he gave a uh quite good speech in which
he slammed the maga movement as
semi-fascism and i think that that's a
pretty good term i sometimes call it
wannabe fascism
uh wet dream fascism
um authoritarian uh uh uh
you know wishing whatever you want to
call it joe biden back out there and
listen these are just empirical
questions there was the feeling that
there was a turnaround that turn around
is very much reflected this is and by
the way if you look
even though the number is still under 42
for biden's approval
the rate at which it increased is
significant and we have not seen that
during biden's presidency
uh so far it matches essentially the
quickest decline that we saw in august
of 2021 as republicans were slamming
biden for the pull out from afghanistan
and coveted numbers were not looking
good this is as rapid an increase as we
have seen a decrease during the biden
presidency and we still have time but it
so far bodes very very well what if i
told you there was something really easy
you could do to speed up your internet
at home and on the go a lot of people
don't know this but it's possible to use
more than one internet connection at the
same time combining the speed and
reliability sort of like combining your
phone's mobile data with the wi-fi from
a hotel or at a coffee shop and our
sponsor speedify is what makes it
possible speedify is the only app that
can combine multiple internet sources
into one bonded super connection to
improve live streaming video calling
gaming web browsing whatever you do
online you can use it on any of your
devices pc mac iphone android linux you
can combine your home wi-fi with your
phone data to create a super connection
that you can use at home it runs in the
background at the click of a button it's
so easy to use
you deserve faster internet right now
lose the video buffering stop the
dropped in the middle of an important
video call issues go to speedify.com
pacman the link is down below